[Music]
it's been an all week on Monday night
Vanessa Lachey and Maksim Chmerkovskiy
reunited on Dancing with the Stars
last week max skipped out on their
performance due to a personal issue he
later apologized to Vanessa on Twitter
after reports world of a feud between
the dancing duo well I like to see you
guys back together again
everything right here you guys are going
good I'm so excited about next week cuz
it's Disney I don't think I can cry
anymore and I don't think I could I
think next week will be a happy you
think I'll cry at Disney once a Disney
Princesses for most memorable year night
Vanessa performed an emotional tribute
to her son Phoenix who was born
premature he's a great teacher and I
listen as the student because this is
not something I do ballroom dance ago he
taught me a rum I've never moved my hips
like that before in my entire life I was
worried that I wasn't gonna be able to
do it but I know I got this guy
literally standing there and he's got my
back Vanessa's hubby Nick who's
competing with Max's wife Peter found
himself in the bottom two for the second
time this season I mean come on what are
we gonna do out there you think they're
messing with us she's still crying gonna
be an emotional no I think I think
everything was sort of like a pressure
cooker
and and everybody wanted to put amazing
steps underneath all these incredible
stories
[Music]